my name is Sergio I'll be talking to you
today about web framework called rocket
that's my email address you'll see it
again at the end of the talk if you want
to chat with me about any of this yeah
so rocket so rocket is a web framework
for rust that ideally makes it simple to
write secure correct web applications
without sacrificing flexibility you
should be able to do what you want not
what the web framework wants you to do
or performance it should be really
really fast even if we have all these
really really nice guarantees just to be
very clear what I mean by web framework
I mean these types of things like Django
or spraying or Rails
you know libraries that help you write
sort of web web back-end code your web
applications back-end and if you're not
familiar with rust it is a programming
language sort of mostly developed by
Mozilla started at Mozilla research that
is memory safe without a garbage
collector using you know PL stuff it has
no data races guaranteed at compile time
if I think compiles then you don't have
any data races and although it also has
a very very very small runtime like on
the order of C++ or even smaller so you
can write things like operating systems
and sort of most most necessary for
rocket is that it has macro systems say
systems because it has two not just one
but two there's sort of the C style
declarative kind of macros but there's
also this different kind of macro called
procedural macro which effectively gives
you an AST at compile time lets you
execute arbitrary rus code that
generates other rust code that is then
inserted into the user's program so this
is what rocket uses sort of most of
rockets niceties and security and
correctness properties come from
procedural macros the fact that we're
able to take a user's web application
and change it explore it verify and
validate it at compile time to give all
these nice guarantees so yeah rocket is
a web framework for us that makes simple
write secure correct web applications
without sacrificing flexibility or
performance now a big part of this talk
will be sort of focusing on the
properties you know the secure the
security and correctness properties that
rocket gives you what I want to
emphasize is that the vast majority of
these properties
are being guaranteed at compile-time
that is if your program compiles you
have all of these guarantees about what
it what it can and cannot do for
instance rocket will guarantee at
compile time that there are no
cross-site scripting or CSRF
vulnerabilities it'll guarantee at
compile time that you don't have any
directory traversal attacks though
guarantee at compile time that you have
no sequel injection attacks if you're
thinkin piles you know I'll do things to
be true okay so this is sort of the
timeline of rocket just to give you an
idea of sort of where it sits in the
world in space and time it launched
about a year and a half ago that was the
first public release about a couple
months after that we had zero point two
and a few months after that we had zero
point three and now it's been a bit bit
later it's been almost I don't know like
eight months after zero point three
people on github seem to like it a lot
it's got 42 hundred stars and Counting I
think I think something really really
interesting is how quickly rocket was
put into production use how quickly
someone told me that they were actually
using rocket in production and you might
guess that this point is sort of farther
on this line you might hope that this
point is sort of sort of farther in the
line but in fact it's right there it was
like a week after rocket was released
someone said that they rewrote their
note application in rocket and their
boss was super happy because they could
toss away you know like a tenth of their
servers or something because it's just
so much faster so that was pretty
interesting now more companies are using
in production my count is and dozens my
guess is roughly 100 or so particular
companies like NPM and system76 and
Mozilla are either using rocket
production today that's NPM and system76
and Mozilla is sort of exploring using
an introduction which is which is pretty
neat ok so yeah once again rocket is a
web framework for us that makes simple
to write secure correct web applications
without sacrificing for somebody or
performance alright so this is a
security workshop so presumably we're
going to talk a lot about security here
so let's talk about security so when I
say rocket helps with security I'm
really talking about all these
vulnerabilities that you might encounter
if you've written a web application and
you know these are them here so all of
these terms here a daily rocket can't
help you
them kind of wanna separate these say
these things into three buckets so the
first I'm gonna say that these are
things that things like spring or rails
sort of already do pretty well so my
color these in green here
things like directory traversal or
cross-site request forgery you know they
they handle it pretty okay if you write
your application in rails or you know
spring boot or something like that then
you're probably not you know vulnerable
to these things now there's a second
class where they kind of try to prevent
these things but still it happens in
practice that a lot of people are
vulnerable to these issues these are
things like cross-site scripting or
remote code execution which you know
you'd think like just don't execute code
though the user gives you but in
practice you know we leak everyone's
social security numbers because you know
we're Experian so these things just
happen so clearly we're not doing a good
job and finally sort of this last class
of things that no one really tackles
because it's just really arbitrary like
what does it mean to validate input that
depends entirely on what the input looks
like it that's very application specific
and so you know something like rails
doesn't really do anything but let you
call functions that say no don't do this
rocket sort of makes it its priority to
handle these things and so yeah so these
are this three to three sort of class of
issues we have these things here that
we're just going to rock is just gonna
use the existing solutions there's no
reason not to they work really well but
on top of that rocket is going to
guarantee that the solutions are
actually enforced if you're think
umpires it will not be vulnerable to
cross-site request forgery so we're
going to use these existing solutions
we're going to do it in such a way that
compiled time we know that they're
enforced this second class of things
sort of similarly we're going to sort of
do what we already know but then we're
gonna go step further for instance for
cross-site scripting we're going to
automatically insert things like CSP
headers so that your thing is guaranteed
to be to not be vulnerable to cross-site
scripting and if you're thinking and the
headers must be inserted I'll never
request and you can't possibly you
couldn't have possibly gotten it wrong
because rocket will do everything for
you or give you a compile time error
that it didn't happen and finally you
know these are things that nothing
really handles
right I'm gonna show you hopefully when
it convince you that rocket has the
tools to sort of solve these issues okay
and if everything works out okay then
we'll be able to color all these things
green and we'll say okay now we have
solutions for everything and we can sort
of write web applications and not be
concerned about all these issues just
kind of write the happy path okay well
so that's kind of cool and there are
sort of three things that rocket does or
three sort of principles that rocket has
that kind of enables it to sort of
handle these things for you so the first
thing that Rocky does a little
differently is that it has no global
state if you use basically any other web
framework there is usually something
global the application is global the
request is global there's some global
state in rocket that's just not the case
in rocket everything is sort of a
function and the functions parameter the
functions declaration contains all the
information necessary to validate and
process that request there is nothing
outside of that function if you see it
in the function it's going to be used
and if it's not in the function it
cannot be used the second is that all of
the requests that are processed by a
rocket application are guaranteed to
have been validated so before any
processing happens before your code
actually executes on a request then
rocket has ensured that that request has
been validated according to your own
policies important according to your
sort of arbitrary policies and this sort
of is happening at the type level so as
you see in a second we have these types
that dictate sort of what things must be
true about a request and rocket will
ensure that those things in fact are
true before it passes use a value of
that type in fact it can't pass you a
value of that type unless those things
are true and finally everything in
rocket is extensible rockets core is
really really small
validation templating serialization
sessions configuration think about it it
doesn't happen in Rockets core it
happens outside so that there's a
canonical contribute in cludes all of
these things that you don't have to
write them yourself but if you wanted to
you could you can completely change the
way validation works in rocket if you
wanted to and the nice thing is that all
these things sort of feel first-class
they don't feel like you're importing a
ruby gem from outside of the world and
you're kind of bold
they just they're just kind of part of
the framework okay so all of these
things sort of make rocket rocket here's
what it looks like so if you have say
you have a paceman and somebody's has
uploaded you know pasted to your website
to your paceman and then trying to
retrieve the paste well there's a few
things that we want to sort of be sure
about to retrieve that pace we want to
make sure that one there is a user
logged in and to that that pace sort of
exists store that the ID that give you
sort of makes sense and so the way you
write this in rocket sort of looks like
this the thing that the very top is an
attribute it declares the thing that
most things that must be true about the
income and request sort of match on it
so in this case we just need an ID from
the user and now the cool thing is that
all of this is typed so sort of in the
request parameters you declare the types
for the incoming request the things that
must be true about the incoming request
in this case there has to be a user
logged in and the ID that you saw in the
sort of request parameter there has to
you know validate as whatever the paste
ID type implies and finally sort of this
extends all throughout the function
declaration this return type sort of
means something it means that you can
optionally return a file you don't
return the file it automatically gives
you a 404 if you do return the file then
it would actually render that file for
whatever that actually means in this
case and then your actual function body
does sort of lookups in this case you
can see that it creates this string that
Zuma bleah is some directory so upload
slash user slash ID and then it just
opens that file now this might look
really really sketchy because well isn't
there like a isn't there like a path
traversal attack going out here like
isn't there a directory traversal attack
here the nice thing is that the answer
is no otherwise I wouldn't be showing
you this all of this is guaranteed to
sort of look the way you wanted to see
there's input validation happening
implicitly
if you got this user type it looks the
way you thought it looked otherwise we
couldn't have created this user type
they got this paste ID type and it looks
the way you wanted to so sort of this
concatenation the thing that you kind of
just want to do just you can do so you
only write the happy path everything
else happens for you okay so I said you
know they're all these sort of security
vulnerabilities you know how does what I
just presented
solve these yeah that's right unless you
wanted to sure you could make you can
make that happen if you wanted to yeah
in this case because we're using it this
way we're sort of assuming that you that
you don't yeah yeah yeah so we have all
these security vulnerability stuff you
know how does this prevent it maybe you
can sort of look ahead and say okay I
see how we're preventing some of these
things but maybe you're not convinced
maybe you even think that hey these
things actually aren't real issues I've
written a lot of web application code
and my code is not vulnerable to these
things well I'm here to tell you you put
probably is and a lot of people's code
is as well and I'm gonna show you three
particular examples that I think are
pretty illustrative of sort of what
happens in the real world so the first
one is WordPress which everyone's
probably familiar with this is the
vulnerability from 2009 this is an
impact 10 vulnerability which means it's
as bad as you can get and it goes like
this
the CVE says that WordPress two for two
point eight point three allows remote
attackers to get privileges via a direct
request to eight different endpoints and
what this means is that if you have a
computer and you're able to make web
requests then you can be an
administrator on any WordPress site the
42.3 by issuing a web request you really
have to do absolutely nothing you just
issue the web request and that's it so
the fix is well let's check that the
person you know the entity executing
this web request is in fact
administrator and how how would you fix
this well if your WordPress and then
you're written in PHP and you insert all
these if statements to check that you
know the user logged in has the certain
permission that you require and here I
show for but in fact they were like
eight or twelve and there was a separate
separate sort of patch set to fix other
issues but sort of the fix here is to
add these if conditions and if you
actually look at these WordPress files
you'll see a bunch of if conditions for
things that look exactly like this sort
by contrast how would we do this in
rocket one rocket we sort of would do
what we just showed in the overview
you'd have this parameter that says oh
this is a user you know so we had this
before in the example so they have this
parameter that says is this user in this
case we don't need a regular user
we need an admin so we change that to be
an admin there so we now require an
admin and now this function can only
execute if there is administrative law
so by virtue of simply declaring that
you didn't need an administrator then
you know you know that this can only
execute if there is in fact an
administrator now you might say well
what if I forgets to actually put this
administrating parameter on there as
sort of wordpress did presumably they
had no data dependency between the
parameter this you know this check and
and you know the fact that it exists so
you know well the nice thing is that we
covered that too
so if you look at this function body
you'll see that we have this file open
sensitive method and the open sensitive
will require a value of type admin in
this case you know this user type and so
what we've created here is a sort of
capability based data dependency ie
we required Advan to exist thus if the
admin exists then we can call this open
sensitive method if this admin does not
exist we can't call this open sensitive
method
thus this open sensitive method can only
be called if an administrator was in
fact authenticated by the request and so
this vulnerability did happen in
WordPress is just caught a compile time
if you can't say that there is an
administrator authenticated you can't
call this sensitive method okay so
that's the wordpress vulnerability
that's why i want to talk about is free
commerce which is a sort of shopping
cart application written in rails is
what Chipotle uses to run their online
store so I don't have a CV for this I
don't know what happened to it they got
rid of it it was weird it exists there
and I didn't I don't know what happened
so the vulnerability goes like this
bypassing the right parameters while
updating a user that user is able to
assign any existing role to themselves
that means if you're Bob and you're just
you know shopping for tacos on
Chipotle's website and you really want
to be the Chipotle administrator then
you just send a particularly crafted web
request and you become B Chipotle
administrator and the vulnerability look
like this they had some code that
updated the user and this is in Ruby so
everything's sort of dynamically typed
and there was this params hash that just
gets the parameters for the incoming web
request so if you were to index it with
this colon user this symbol then you
would get all of them all of the
properties that the user passed in and
then what the function did what the
method did was update to the current
user too
those parameters so this is some magical
Ruby dynamic stuff happening here which
would be really difficult to do in a
language like Russ which is statically
typed but sort of what goes wrong here
is this the user passes in a a property
of role as a parameter then you just
update the role in the user sort of it
just takes whatever the user passed in
and saves that to the database that's so
that's the other thing going on here and
rails everything is sort of tied to the
database so if you update your user
object it updates the user object in the
database now this is this is sort of one
instance of a really big class of
vulnerabilities that kind of impacted
the entire rails world because this is
the canonical way to write a rails
application you sort of do this max
assignment thing and everyone was like
this is awesome and we can do this in
Ruby and rails until they realized oh
the whole thing is actually a
vulnerability which was termed of Massah
simonv ulnar ability so a bunch of web
applications sort of had to stop doing
the canonical thing to fix themselves
now how would it how would this look
like in rocket well in rocket if you
wanted to take parameters from the
outside world well as with everything
else in rocket they have to be typed so
if you wanted oh sorry this is the fix
this is what they did to fix it
they just deleted the role from the
incoming parameters so that was pretty
funny because well you guys see this you
okay yeah so in rocket if you wanted to
actually do something like this well
you'd have to type the incoming
parameters so it looked kind of like
this yeah some structure call it a user
and then you specify the field so say
they had a name or an age and you know
whatever other things and then you
declare your route over here and you
would say I'm expecting some data and
the data is gonna have the parameter
name user and the type for that is going
to be a form that is going to
deserialize into a user all right and
what rocket will do is it'll generate
all the code for you so this derived
from form on top of this user struct
generates the DC realization code for a
for a form coming in as a user and then
you know on line eight here that
declares this user type to be of that
form type which is what actually is
going to execute the dis realization
automatically for you and so there's no
pub if they pass in a role field D
serialization will fail you can also ask
it to succeed but in any case you're not
going to keep that data so there's no
way for you to ever possibly save
role in the database if you do it this
way that would be really really weird
okay so that's pre Commerce the last
thing I want to talk about is get lab
get lab is a sort of github open source
github alternative kind of thing and
they had this cool feature we could if
you were an administrator impersonate
any other user so you could see you know
how they see their their github their
git repositories or whatever and they
had a vulnerability associated with this
this is CV 2016 40 to 40 impact 8.8 it
was a ten and they downgraded it to an
eight point eight I don't really know
what it means at that point but yeah and
it goes like this it says they had a
blog post and they said we discovered a
critical security flaw the impersonate
feature was not properly secured it was
possible for any authenticated user
administrator or not to log in as any
other using any other user including
administrators so that meant that anyone
could be anyone else on any get live
instance just pretty bad so just wanna
quickly show you sort of what
authentication and authorization looks
like in this in this rails application
you sort of saw what we would do in
rocket by having an admin type that
automatic F indicates an authority
if you were do this and something like
rails it looks very very different this
is the attack by the way you log in you
get an authenticity token you then send
a request and that's it that's literally
the entire attack so it's a very very
very simple attack you just need to grab
a cookie from your browser and then send
an HTTP request with those parameters
filled in and then your whoever you want
to be your that username okay this is
the code that sort of led to that don't
worry about most of it worry about this
little part here so this is what
actually does the authorization
authentication this authorizes
impersonator sort of hopefully does what
you expect it checks the session and it
tries to find that user and it checks
with that user is an administrator in
this impersonation controller thing they
have this before action this is
something it's supposed to execute
before anything else executes so they
say before action authorize the
impersonator okay but they also have a
skip before action which says under
certain conditions don't do these things
so skip before action do not
authenticate the administer
if you're doing a destroy okay so
destroy is actually gonna be the method
that's gonna be sort of vulnerable here
so what they've written is if this
destroying method gets called at any
point by rails don't attenti Kate the
admin but do authenticate the
impersonator that sounds okay I suppose
so what sort of goes wrong sort of what
does destroying method does is it you
know checks if there's a person who
logged in and it sets the user to be
able to be the parameter that was passed
in by the impersonator and you sort of
redirect to wherever you need to go you
know to the to the person you're
impersonating page and the hope is that
this destroy method doesn't run unless
the person is allowed to impersonate
someone because if they can well then
anyone can be anyone they want and the
problem is that this authorized
impersonator method is wrong because if
there's not an impersonator ID in the
session then this if case doesn't run
and you don't do any authentication at
all and because it's Ruby you sort of
get this nil which presumably evaluates
the true or something and then this
destroy method just kind of runs which
is which is pretty bad so clearly this
would look nothing mean we would just
have like an impersonator type in rocket
and we would sort of guard this destroy
method by that type and none of this
would happen okay so those are just
three three sort of examples and there's
there's just so many of these happens
all the time these are three notable
examples that impacted you know
presumably millions and millions of
people okay so now I'm going to tell you
about rocket that was a fancy animation
cool now I'm going to tell you about
rocket show you a hello world of rocket
which is basically a an overview of the
overview so here's our hello world this
is the simplest rocket application that
we can write the thing appear we call it
route attributes again this is just a
description of the matching conditions
this one says we're gonna handle all get
requests to the route path this thing
down here is the handler it's the thing
that's actually going to do the
processing and as we saw before it's
gonna include a bunch of types that
actually validate the request and
eventually it's going to produce a
response in this case it produces a
string that is in the static in the
binary itself
okay and that's it that's really what
rocket applications look like they're
just composed of routes that look
exactly like this and if you were to run
this you'd get this hello world so you
just go to localhost 8 eight thousand
and see hello world pretty simple I need
to write just a little bit more if you
want to actually get this thing to
compile and run you need to tell rocket
about this route so you do this by
mounting the thing and then you pass in
the name of the route and just in this
case it's called hello and then you call
launch to actually start the application
so the sequence is ignite to turn on the
rocket mount to put mounts on to put
handlers on the rocket and launch to
actually launch the rocket in practice
if you have a rocket put things on to it
before you ignite it that's the general
sequence of things ok so you call launch
and that actually starts up the server
so rocket sort of has its own server it
also prints some emojis for fun and it
looks like this it sort of tells you all
of the configuration that it knows about
if it finds any issues with the
configuration it will immediately abort
and if it doesn't it'll start and then
you can go to that local holes localhost
there's a lot more to rocket and tell
you about a couple of things I don't
have time to tell you about everything
I'm tell you about three features so the
first is dynamic paths and don't really
pads we already saw I'm just gonna tell
you about them in a bit more detail show
you how this thing is actually working
so dynamic paths are those things in
brackets at the top there at the top of
the route and parameters and brackets
will match any text that's applied in
that URL segment so if you do slash Bob
slash pipe you know 50 then name will be
bub and age will be 50 and these things
are these things are matched to function
arguments so they have to have a
function argument of the same name if
you have a function argument with a
different name so let's say we change
aged number then you get an error at
compile time
and the error tries to be very helpful
it'll tell you hey you gave me this age
variable this age parameter but you
didn't say have anything in the function
declaration here's what your function
equation actually it looks like so go
fix it so we fix that
you know then everything works okay
every parameter is also associated with
the type this is just rust and in
particular in rocket every type has to
implement a certain interface and rust
we call them traits but you can think
about them as Java interfaces or NGO
interfaces or interfaces basically
everywhere like Haskell type classes and
any type that implements the from
parameter face is allowed in that
position that includes your own types so
here rocket has implemented them for the
sort of standard library type string and
u8 which is an 8-bit integer but you can
have their own types we saw like user
and paste ID before so you can implement
them for whatever you want and then sort
of when this executes when this when
when this when there is a request that
matches this these parameters this get
/name /parent ation which actually does
the validation and conversion so in this
case for the age parameter or actually
check if it can parse it as an 8-bit
integer if it can
it'll parse it as an API integer and
then pass it in as the H parameter and
so this is how we get sort of in this
particular case a tiny form of input
validation for segments and parameters
so one place where this is kind of fun
sort of what this is totally applicable
is in preventing directory traversal
attacks so if we have this code here
which is going to fetch a file from our
file system so here that get the
attribute says that we want any path the
dot dot says not only give me this
segment but every other segment
thereafter and the type of that thing is
path buff which is a heap allocated pack
and rockets implementation for from per
M is actually going to verify that the
path is safe to be used as a suffix to
any other path in particular sort of
what Dan was alluding to before it'll
ensure that there are no dot dots in
that path and it'll do it'll it'll make
that path canonical so you can use it as
a suffix and so that means that we can
write a static file server literally in
four lines like this we just take the
path and then we prepend it with another
path and we return that if it exists
that's it so this is how you write a
sort of four line
static file server in rocket that is
immune to a directory traversal attack
she's pretty funny okay so that's really
all I want to say about theirs it's not
too difficult to sort of do this dynamic
parameter thing where gets much more
interesting as sort of trying to be
arbitrary about the input validation
that you're trying to do and the
mechanism the rocket has for this we
call request guards so request guards I
think are the most interesting part
about rocket that's sort of I haven't
seen any of the web priming that has
anything like request cards which is
really fun so what are requests guards
so request guards are these parameters
that appear in your route that don't
have a matching parameter in the
attribute so we here we have get slash
admin admin is not in brackets thus it's
not sort of one of these dynamic
parameters and but we still have this
admin parameter inside of the function
and because it doesn't have a metric
parameter in the attribute it's called a
request garden you can have as many of
these as you want here we just have one
began as many of these as you want and
the restriction on these types is that
they have to implement a different trait
a different type plus a different
interface call it from request and it
can do whatever it wants just like we
saw before we had a user and then we had
this admin type here we have an admin
user type which presumably means that
it's just an admin that's also a user
and it'll rock it will run these for you
automatically and it will only execute
your function your handler if these
validations hold true okay so yeah so
these request cards they validate the
incoming requests and they protect
handlers from running under you know in
readiness conditions the guards may fail
ie if you don't have an admin logged in
then the guard will fail and the request
won't be processed any further because
that indicates that there's something
wrong with the incoming request the
guard may also forward which indicates
that it has failed sort of for now but
something else might be able to to
process this request in the future and
I'll make this a little clearer in just
a second so let's say we have sort of
another another route here so you notice
that they both match get slash admin so
it's sort of there's no ordering with
just get slash admin so to give an
ordering you have to you have to you
call these colliding routes to give an
ordering you have to give them a rank
and if you don't give them a rank so say
you just had this
then so you can give a rank to sort of
fix it if you don't give it a rank if
you have just this then rocket will sort
of complain and tell you there are
colliding routes and it has to do this
at run time because wrath can be
generated dynamically so unfortunately
we can't do it compile time we have to
do at run time but before the
application does anything all this stuff
is checked so this is again sort of
trying to fix miss configuration issues
and it'll tell you exactly which routes
are colliding and you know give you a
hint about how to fix it particularly
using ranking ok so if we go back and
rank these rocket will try colliding
routes in ascending rank order so first
it'll try the route at the top and then
it will try the next round so what's
gonna happen here is if someone makes a
request to the slash admin path a get
request then that first route will run
which requires they're there to be an
admin user logged in so that's gonna do
something like check the cookies for a
session ID you know check the database
for that session check that that
identify the user or check that the role
for that user is an admin and if so sort
of deserialize the stuff in the database
into this admin user type and finally
return so do all the things it needs to
do if that forwards that means try the
next thing try the next route in the
chain if it if it fails then it won't
try anything else so in this case if it
forwards it'll try that route at the
bottom this one also has sort of
requirement that there is a user logged
in not an admin user but sort of just a
regular user and so in this case if
there's a regular user logged in it'll
execute that second route and if it
can't if it forwards it'll try the next
one
if there is no next one it will 404 if
it fails it will sort of 404 immediately
or 400 depending on how it's sort of
implemented and you can sort of extend
this further so we have a third route if
this user type forwards then it'll go to
this third route that's rank three
routes in this case there are no
requirements for the request there's no
there are no types in the input which
means that you don't need any sort of
validation those will always run so if
you imagine this sort of a real
application this is sort of implementing
authorization and authentication if
there's an admin user presumably given
the admin panel
the first thing runs if there is a
regular user you sort of give them you
know you tell them hey you need to be
administrator to actually acts as the
admin panel and if there is no one
logged in then you redirect them to the
login page
so this is sort of implementing
authorization well not sort of this is
implementing authorization and
authentication and sort of the policy
for what it means to have certain roles
for an admin panel in one go and rocket
is kind of doing everything for you just
sort of write the happy case if there's
an admin do this if the resident admin
but there's a user do this if there is
nothing then do this other thing
okay so that's sort of the combination
of oppressed guards in forwarding which
i think is the most interesting part
here now the last sort of feature I want
to talk about is type your eyes and this
is sort of looking into how rocket tries
to try to help you in terms of
correctness so let's say you have a
route that looks like this you're
employing some kind of shopping cart or
something and you allow people to get an
item of a certain kind so like a shirt
or something and have a certain ID like
23 or something so you're gonna run this
you know someone request this product
with that ID you're gonna return them
the item and that's gonna render it
somehow so if you want to get a URL to a
particular product while you need to
have a valid product name and a valid ID
so one thing you could do is you can
just you know create this random string
so you can sort of do string
interpolation with the word shirt and
with the number of 2417 and get a string
but shirt may no longer be a product
like say you stop using shirt as a
product or you know this URL just
changed completely
instead of inventory you headed
somewhere else and who knows if 24 17 is
a valid ID so sort of the problem here
is we want to create these your eyes but
we also want to make sure that these
your eyes are correct let's do that
we're gonna use the type information
when you use the fact that product has
to be the type product an ID has to be a
you size to sort of create valid IDs
instead of doing this format thing we're
gonna do this URI thing we're gonna say
you are a bang for the router named item
pass in the type parameters product
shirt and the number 24 17 and what rock
is gonna do is gonna you know check
these things against the actual route so
sort of if you if you want to pass in
the names you can do that you can flip
them around but if you get them wrong so
if you do item equals product shirt and
you can see that there's no item
parameter in the URL then rocket will
complain it'll say you try to pass in a
parameter name item but there's no such
parameter
in the route and so this thing will just
fail compile-time if you get the wrong
type you're gonna get the same issue I'm
gonna get not the same error but similar
here and finally if everything sort of
works out okay you're gonna get this
you're gonna get this string at compile
time so all of this is sort of happening
at compile time the type checking is
happening compile time the name of URL
parameters is checking is happening
compile time so you really can't get
your eyes wrong if you change you know
this route to have a different URI later
this this thing is guaranteed to fail to
compile if it's changed in a typing
compatible way so just the sort of a
small way but a very helpful way that
rocket tries to fix correctness issues
and applications okay so that's most of
what I want to say about about Rockets
now there is one last thing that I sort
of mentioned in this introduction thing
which was performance so the last thing
I want to talk about is sort of how
rocket does in comparison to other web
frameworks and so I compared it against
sort of what people are using nowadays
there is no Java which presumably is
what people are using an enterprise but
so I don't compare it against Java my
guess is somewhere between what I did
compare it against what I did compare it
against are these sort of three web
frameworks rails which is the Ruby web
framework express which is a node web
framework and flask which is a Python
web primary sort of a minimalistic
Python web framework and then rocket so
this is a measure of throughput this is
on a sort of 12 core eight nine year old
machine so Stephen will run this in your
own servers you're gonna get you know
four or five six x what we see here yeah
so this is through punch so rocket gets
around 38,000 requests per second here
Express is the next leader
this is node this is JavaScript this is
around 20 27 or so so rocky gets around
12,000 more across per second and
Express and it you know both of them do
significantly better better than what
you get in neither rails or flask so
this is okay we really really see really
big differences and this is a lot is a
lot is a lot to do with language that
it's written in is when we look at
latency so these are the numbers for
latency this is average latency so rails
Express and flask
all have sort of this is on woven
network by the way obviously you're not
gonna see sub microseconds C on this
on the internet that's it that'd be
awesome but not gonna see that anytime
soon this is on a local network it's
sort of rails Express and flask
don't do don't do so great but what's
sort of even more shocking is what the
tail looks like what the tail latency
looks like so if we look if we look at
the 99.99% tail or 99.95% tail we see
this which is really rather
extraordinary I mean it's so hard to
read that I had to change it to this log
scale here to kind of make sense of this
so the rocket is the only thing with
still sub microsecond latency and
everything else is magnitudes worse so
you know rocket and rust don't have a
garbage collector there's never a
garbage collection pause my guess is
that we're seeing this because rails
express in flask well you know all of
these things are have garbage collectors
so my guess is that we just caught them
at their garbage collection time and
that's what we see these really really
bad latency is really really bad tail
latency yeah so rocket really just does
seem like significantly better in this
case so these are this is these are the
two combined things so there's average
latency and Max latency just to give you
an overview of comparison this is really
where rocket shines see it also has much
higher throughput and effectively
everything else but it has really much
better leading to them reveals these are
the three graphs just to give an
overview of this thing looks like we
have a lot of plants to make rockets
significantly faster this is sort of
very preliminary with almost zero sort
of performance optimization ever I mean
no weird performance optimizations
effort this is just right reasonable
code and and you know do the right thing
kind of thing whereas something like
rails has had almost a decade of
performance work and this stuff put into
it okay so that's that really is all I
want to say about rocket if you want to
learn more about rocket oh that's all I
want to say there's a bunch of stuff
here as a bunch of stuff I didn't talk
about there's a bunch of stuff that it
that it does I just cannot cover and the
time that I have particular I talked a
lot about CSRF and cross-site scripting
prevention and that comes through its
tight type templating engine sort of
these are templates they get compiled
and they compile
they're guaranteed to be immune to CSRF
in cross-site scripting vulnerabilities
there's a lot of stuff that happens we
type everything so you type body data
you get automatic you sterilization
with forms we type queries things
strings we type database connections and
there's a built-in unit integration
testing framework so these are all
things that you know you kind of want if
you're gonna write production
applications and we have at least
hundreds of production users so you know
they like these things okay so this is
the website if you want to learn more
about rockets you can go to this website
that's Rocket ORS there's a guide
there's a tutorial
there are documentation API Doc's
there's news and there's a link to the
github repository rocket is MIT and the
pocha - poner license you choose that's
me again I'm Sergio that's my email
address and thank you so much for
listening
[Applause]
yeah a little bit yeah so the question
is gonna compare with some web
frameworks and go or mozi language to
profess seems fun yeah so C++ is sort of
a completely different world because
it's not memory safe right so if you
write your thing as C++ and you expose
it to the world on the Internet
sort of it's probably not a good idea so
I would never write a web application if
C++ for that very reason so this really
different class of thing
now go is go is memory safe and it's
sort of kind of built to do networking
applications it's a really good thing to
compare it against when I did
performance measurements it's the thing
that comes closest to rocket in fact it
beats rocket in some throughput tests it
still has the same latency issues rocket
is just really sort of far again start
far ahead in terms of latency but go has
had a lot of effort put into sort of
throughput and so it does really really
well now the big difference is that sort
of all of this stuff that I talked about
that rocket does you can sort of emulate
and go a little bit like this floor arms
parsing thing you can sort of emulate it
and go but it's all dynamic there is no
compiled time anything that tells you if
this is happening it's all through sort
of dynamic introspection and so you can
have type errors at runtime
because someone passing in the wrong
form and you didn't specify the right
values and you're you know when your
form attributes or whatever yeah so the
really really big difference is that
and nothing where it really has this
property but you get all these checks at
compile time there is no performance
regulation as a result and you have
guarantees if you're thinking piles
that's the really really big difference
here yeah a couple of questions yeah I
think there are two problems here one is
you know a framework providing the right
syntax and semantics to write secure
code and the second one is the
developers not using it yeah
so this provides very tight syntax and
semantics to write secure code if the
developer doesn't write those policies
you know you mention request cards typed
URI so functions with right arguments
and all that does that prevent that yeah
I mean if you do it wrong it's gonna be
wrong that's for sure yeah so we have no
way of saying like definitely do the
right thing now there are some things
that they can't escape they can't escape
cross-site scripting you know validation
they can't escape CSRF they can't escape
injection and safety for arbitrary
policies yeah they can do the wrong
thing if you're gonna validate a user
and gonna write the wrong code to valid
that user we can't really do anything
except give them a library that does it
for them so they can't get it wrong now
the thing where I still so so let me let
me let me do sort of two things here one
let me sort of give you anecdotes and
then two let me sort of give you a more
formalized version of these anecdotes
so one what I've seen is that when
people do the wrong thing they become an
IRC they come on you know they come chat
with me and they say hey I did this
thing it feels really really wrong I'm
allocating everywhere and I don't know
and I'll take a look at their code and
it'll be vulnerable and so there is
something to say about sort of the way
that rocket forces you to do this
validation in the first place gets
people to think that they might be doing
the wrong thing or that what they're
doing is sort of no very risky and so
sort of anecdotally I've seen a lot of
people that do the right thing that
don't say anything but say hey here's
the application people do the wrong
thing that say this feels weird what's
going on and they're doing the wrong
thing now it's sort of more formally
speaking I think something that rocket
really enables and something I really
want to explore more is that it lets you
sort of containerize I hate that word
sort of I mean we not use that word hate
that word lets you type your validation
right there's nothing else that says
given a type user I know all of these
must be true and so if you're you know a
company then all you have to do is have
a library that says validation rocket
validations and then ship that across
their application so you have you know
your three four or five most trusted
developers right these types and
everyone else just uses them and because
it's so easy to use the type that's
given to you with rocket then there's
like really little incentive not to and
thus much more probability they're gonna
get it right so sort of that's an
argument towards reducing the amount of
code that has to be written and the
amount of an increase in the amount of
code we used to get anything right yeah
thanks yeah yeah I have a couple of
questions starts with question so
framework related what liabilities are
getting primed nowadays like drugs and
spraying and so on and so forth so are
you getting a similar trend in rocket
trend what sorry I missed the first part
of the question like framework related
but liabilities reporting by third party
researcher or open source posix yeah
like spring starts and etc so those are
getting more concentrated towards the
vulnerabilities disclosures similarly do
you seeing any trend in rocket towards
having like security vulnerabilities
been disclosed well we've had one
security vulnerability thus far and it
was in 0.1 and so yeah so people are
letting us know there's something wrong
with rocket and it was like an edge case
with IE like ie6 or something in fact in
the directory traversal prevention stuff
so we fix that immediately so yeah I
mean no one else is found a security
problem and that doesn't mean they don't
exist look at it take a look Dan Dan was
concerned about our cookie handling code
so we made it more robust I'm still not
convinced there was an exploit there but
now it's more robust so yeah I mean
we've had one and a half sort of reports
you know my game account is about ten
thousand users using rocket so either
they're not telling us or they're not
finding issues I don't know
second question is we use any third
parties bundled with the framework sorry
a third party like look for say or any
of the common libraries for logging
logging or similar do you have any third
parties bundled within the frame
we don't but there are several companies
that have written their own and not
release them so yeah we don't have
anything that rocket ships but if
someone who's already written in if you
want to write it you know I contribute
it we'll put it in rocket it is a
milestone issue for a version 0.5 you
know there will be some runs some
logging solutions you know next question
is if one want to define framework level
definition definitions like you said get
request is that if I want to restrict
myself to the post only when I'm
defining application or creating
application is there any such
configuration exist in the rocket so you
only want post yes routes yeah I mean
yeah yeah we really question yeah so
sort of is there any application level
validation that you can do in rocket and
the example is can I restrict my rocket
my rocket application to only have post
requests to only take in post requests
yeah so there are two things you could
do so one you could catch it before your
application even launches by rocket lets
you inspect all of the routes that have
been registered so you can just
integrate them in route and say oh
that's that's not a post route and just
cancel there alternatively you if you
want to sort of stop it when the request
happens then you have this middleware
type stuff and you can just check is
this supposed to cross or not and if
it's not just cancel it yeah so you
could you know do it sort of at the
beginning or dynamically yeah you can do
it everyone next question is you talked
about performance and you talked about
security but you didn't talk about
scalability so do you see any bottleneck
in rocket scalability I mean it sort of
scales to many core machines that's for
sure
we haven't npm is the you know they have
millions and millions of users so they
have started deploying it to production
and i have not received an angry email
yet so my guess is it also scales to
millions of users now I don't I don't
know but you we don't give you any sort
of interesting tools to scale it or not
AWS you know you're gonna have to do
your own scaling but as far as the
software itself is concerned I have no
reason to believe it doesn't scale to
millions of users
yeah okay type based validation that
you're doing it seems pretty interesting
for almost any network protocol not just
HTTP of course HTTP a thousand pound
gorilla but how hard would it be to
extend this basic concept to other
network protocols that have similar
problems know how to do we've already
done it yeah so yes what protocols have
you - for arbitrary protocols is what
we've done yeah so we have sort of a
framework where you sort of annotate
your thing and then it calls something
else to finish whatever it means to
process that annotation so where we've
seen someone apply this is to do like G
RPC sort of doing a similar thing yeah
it seems to be what you want good so G
RPC is where we seen it applied but you
can do it for like soap you can do it
for whatever or you can do it for your
own no networking protocols yeah so and
we've an extended asfar like system
calls which kind of look like our pcs or
anything that kind of looks like RPC
this this fits in perfectly so we've
done it for like system calls where
someone calls you and you need to
validate all the inputs before you
actually do any processing so yeah this
is kind of a general mechanism but it's
really well suited for yeah the question
is sort of how easy is it for someone to
grok this new syntax so so it sort of
looks a lot like flask which is the
Python web framework so a lot of people
kind of feel comfortable just kind of
looking at it in that in that way but
even then you still have to sort of know
rust
now the thing that so I don't know we'd
have to you like a some weird study or
some sort but what is really cool is
that from what I've gathered a non
insignificant amount of new rust users
start using rust because of rocket yeah
so that was really really shocking
you'll see so an IRC there's a rust
beginners thing almost say hey I just
started writing a new rocket
applications the first time writing rust
you know I'm running into this issue and
so it's at least inviting enough that
people feel okay with doing it and on
github there's 3800 rocket applications
most of them seem to by people that have
a single rust repository which is rocket
so people are writing things that have
never written rust before and succeeding
for the most part yeah yeah that's cool
definitely alright awesome thank you
[Applause]